bon je vais mettre celui là ici ça ça
ira là bon ben voilà ah bonjour excusez
moi je ne voudrais pas vu je suis
tellement occupé aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
le temps de m'occuper de vous j'ai un
travail énorme et très important je doit
réunir ici tous les objets pour
constituer un bric à brac pour la
prochaine fête de l'île aux enfants
c'est une responsable ical in ear un
joli bonjour tiens regarde ce que je
t'ai importé pour ton riga rock très bel
objet merci très content j'ai très bon
parfum à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure c'est bien ça oui bon
je disais mais qu'est ce que ça ira
françois pas mal ce salido ouais ça te
ferait plaisir à l'autre objet pour ton
premier oui alors qu'ils ne regardent
pas mal hein c'est bien c'est très bien
je m'achète mais je me suis permis de
vous apporter ceci entre deux réunions
très importante et une plume que je
tiens de mon père tune lui-même le tiers
de son grand père à tout à l'heure
mais c'est léger enfin les billions
casimir rangs même du a vraiment un très
bel étalage ah oui ça commence à être
important dit dont tu crois pas qu'il
faudrait mettre une étiquette sur chaque
objet ah ben oui oui je les étiquettes
là tu les as formidable hasard une
étiquette voilà sur chaque objet
là mais j'ai dit non casimir casimir way
sur les étiquettes
il faut écrire le nom de l'objet
correspondant à oui oui il faut le no
way évidemment ça se passe il s'est fait
fort est pas difficile enfants et bien
moi j'ai l'impression que tu as besoin
d' aide non oui n'aurait elle donc et à
laisser les enfants les enfants les
enfants venaient casimir a besoin de
votre aide vous voyez tous ces objets
les enfants casimir ne connaît pas leurs
noms voulais l'aider d'accord je connais
certains noms mais partout ces émirs du
nous montre le premier objet le premier
objet voilà qu'est ce que c'est que ça
les enfants c'est un pied-de-biche
nicolas et s'assure la qualifie de niche
[Musique]
ont levé les clous effectivement on
prend le coup comme ça on fait basculer
et hop le clou par bombes et autres
objets casimir moi je les avais vu des
biches avec des pieds pareil enfin bon
ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça les
enfants un tournevis qui sera ici et
détourner les bises quoi comme son nom
l'indiqué sa mère est le digne arracher
les clous et autre chose que mails cette
chose là bas ce n'est pas du tout quoi
ça sert
c'est une agrafeuse agrafeuse ça sert à
quoi
oui pour tapisser une pièce et on appuie
là je ne sais pas pourquoi pour pas de
blessés c'est ça c'est que ça les ans
une petite poêle comme ça mais des
heurts des petites crêpes whaou est un
petit 10 steaks et c'est rohff
je le fais c'est pas une case pour
casimir est un peu petit ça casserait
nick et moi ça sert pour écumer temps
venu du chou on retire les cuves du
dessus voilà moi je m'en faire pour
chasser les moustiques
vous pourrez croiser les moustiques
autorisé mais un autre choc est à toi
s'annonce aussi les cle's évidemment pas
facilement jamais besoin c'est toujours
ouvert chez moi ça qu'est ce que ça ça
sert à quoi ça casimir attirer les
bouchons parfait ce débouché des records
à démontrer j'ai là ce bel objet comme à
apporter julie oui et ça tourne
qu'est ce que c'est ah bon kim à dire
les choses et celui là alors qu'est ce
qu'on écoute la bête
cette fois ci pas si on écoute les
points ça s'appelle un panier à poissons
le bouricha poisson une fois qu'on a
attrapé le poisson pour le mas
l'intérieur ils trempent dans l'eau bon
je croyais que c'était une cage à
oiseaux poissons c'est pareil
bon qu'est ce qu'a dû encore à son
démarrage qu'est ce que c'est
mais un moulin à café moulin à café
on met le café c'est au tour de john
kirwan
les deux très bien ça françois tient
jeudi dans sa chambre et j'ai passé
casimir haut-rhin et clients pour ça que
je te rends ton vieux morceaux de
chambre à air a dit apporter ça qu'ils
aient mis un monsieur du sne en ses murs
du snob
autrefois on écrivait un vrai qu on le
tremper dans l'encré dans écrivait avec
tient très joli 5 ans fait aussi à se
chatouiller les oreilles mais que des
oreilles plus qu'aisé mieux non mais je
pourrais tu chatouiller les tiennent
ensuite une petite chose là qu'est ce
que c'est que c'est tout dit une lime
une lime à quoi à ongles c'est une
l'imam et aux relations gaz émis 1 pour
te faire les ongles
1 qu'est ce que ça veut dire
lundbeck processeur sb crouch février
qui seraient liées comme ça on lapierre
s'est rapproché du snob qui se joint à
nous qu'est ce que c'est que ça ah bah
voilà les trous par où sortent amateurs
alors un objet contenant toutes les
villes du pays
toute la musique et a appuyé musical qui
sifflent celui-là qu'on autorise un
score wifi et ça c'est une pince
d'électricien
voilà et c'est pas l'être et la partie à
qui celles-ci à votre vie à casimir lui
donne enfin c'est la folie de casimir
fois tu as raison un très grand pas à
moi tu à autre chose un bel objet et là
oh oui libre effectivement qu'est ce que
c'est que ça les enfants
me mouiller maarten menuisier 7 martin
et sept autres comédies comme le pied de
biche tout à l'heure aux ide restent les
amis enfin dernier petit marteau le l'or
est mignon celui-là oui très bien rémi
elodie comment ça marche
à quoi sert cette partie qu'est ce que
c'est oui ça parfait parfait bonne
explication bon je vais pouvoir faire
tout mais et piqué on a tous vu que j'ai
mis tout est bien casé lui je te
félicite tu as très bien travaillé en
remercie monsieur du snop
en tant que président de la fête je te
donne le droit de choisir l'objet que tu
veux merci monsieur le président un même
si c'est le plus bel objet ou même si
c'est le plus bel objet oui c'est vrai
bon alors je vais choisir un os
voilà ce vieux morceaux de sombres r
ouais mais qu'est ce que tu veux en
faire môssieur du scabb 9 savez-vous pas
que la chambre à air avec de la crème
chantilly c'est mon dessert favori au 15
heures
[Musique]